the shape of water was directed by
Guillermo del Toro and star Sally
Hawkins Michael Shannon Octavia Spencer
and Doug Jones and is the story of a
mute woman who works at a science
facility in the 1960s who encounters an
aquatic creature it's been captured it's
being experimented on and something
about this just doesn't sit right with
her she's also a woman who feels a
little incomplete not just because she's
not able to speak but because she feels
unfulfilled in her life as a result of
that her neighbor played by Richard
Jenkins is an artist who also feels very
unfulfilled and can't seem to find his
place in life and Hawkins and Spencer
both play janitors who clean this
research facility so this gives them
access to certain areas that they
normally wouldn't have access to that
other government officials can only go
in as a result Hawkins starts to develop
a relationship with this creature and we
have a movie now del Toro's last few
films have disappointed me I wasn't a
humongous fan of Pacific Rim it was
alright as an anime fan I should have
loved that movie and crimson peak I
didn't really like it all and so going
into the shape of water I was excited
based off of his knack for incredible
visuals alone but when I left I was
impressed not just with the visuals but
with the astounding performances and
that theme of being incomplete being
unfulfilled because so many characters
in this movie feel that way even Michael
Shannon as the evil villain the
government official who is torturing
this creature and trying to learn from
it even he doesn't feel like he's
reached his levels of greatness yet
everyone in this film has something
about them that feels incomplete
something that they haven't been able to
attain or something they desire and they
need a void filled and for Sally Hawkins
character this creature fills that void
because the creature doesn't understand
the fact that she's mute they learned to
communicate through sign language and so
he doesn't look at her as an incomplete
person anymore and this is one of the
few people or things that she's ever
encountered that looks at her that way
and so immediately she's taken aback by
that so yes it is a story about a woman
and a weird fish monster
and it's kind of a love story which
could be a little creepy for some people
and kind of a turn-off but it's not just
about that it's about being unfulfilled
in life and how we can fill these voids
in the people or things that we meet
it's brilliantly acted Sally Hawkins is
terrific here and I think she deserves
an Oscar nomination honestly Richard
Jenkins is also quite good as his
Octavia Spencer Michael Shannon Michael
Stalberg everyone in this movie is
giving top-notch work but let's talk
about the visuals because they leap off
the screen this is a visual masterwork
it's beautifully directed the
cinematography is a lush the colours
explode off of the screen it's one of
the best looking films of the year by
far and if it doesn't get nominated for
Best Cinematography I would be surprised
this is a gorgeous gorgeous movie and
del Toro once again has proven that he
has such a knack for beautiful
production design and choosing people to
work in this set to make it look as best
as it can because so much of this movie
is gratefully in-camera Doug Jones as
this creature the suit that he wears and
all of that makeup and prosthetic work
is beautiful
as for issues with the movie I would say
towards the third act it gets a little
bit cheesy and a little predictable I
could see where it was going and it
seemed like it ended at some point but
then it continued to go on some of the
pacing is a little bit affected by a
sort of strange event that occurs and a
side story that doesn't always live up
to what the rest of the film is doing
and I could have used a little more time
at the facility building this
relationship between Sally Hawkins and
the creature because once certain things
happen it does feel a little rushed but
besides that I think this is a beautiful
movie with one of Sally Hawkins best
performances a great side plot with
Richard Jenkins that I did not expect
that really says a lot about not just
the 1960s but unfortunately today as
well and it's really powerful Octavia
Spencer really good Michael Shannon
everybody in the film shines and instead
of just falling back on Creature from
the Black Lagoon cliches it has a
startling message about how we fill the
voids in our life
and being unfulfilled as people and I
thought it was really great I'm gonna
give the shape of water and a - guys
thank you so much as always for watching
I'm gonna be going to Chicago here in a
few days to do something kind of fun
with some people who live there if you
guys are fans of channel awesome and
savage a critic Doug Walker and all the
great people over there I'm gonna be
doing some stuff for them and we might
have a little collaboration coming out
very soon on my channel and on his
channel something's kind of silly and um
on my channel we're just gonna review
like a random movie but the the really
cool things gonna happen over at channel
awesome so look forward to that guys
thank you so much as always for watching
and if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]